can you hear
me yeah I can hear you can you hear me
okay yes I can where you from UK the UK
all right welcome to the panel man
welcome to the panel thanks so how would
you like to engage with it uh how would
you prove that Jesus is a
Muslim yeah I mean he prayed didn't he
he he bowed on the
floor he went into prostration like the
Muslims do
okay where' you get that
from I'm sure that's in your Bible
somewhere that is true it is in the
Bible that Jesus prostrates and so
you're saying that this is a proof that
he's a
muslim okay I reckon so yeah yeah I mean
like he's consistent he preached
worshiping the one
God's one one at a time one at a time
let's talk about how he prostrated so in
the Bible it says when he prostrated it
says and going a little further he fell
on his face and prayed saying father if
it be possible let this cup pass for me
but not my will let your will be done so
he's prostrating to his
father um is that how Muslims pray do
they prostrate to their father in
Heaven always say father was used like
in a figurative sense in in the
past when referring to God obviously we
we don't refer to God as father we refer
to him as Allah right so you guys don't
pray like that then
right the actions are the same and the
actions are the same he prostrated he
put his head ground he put his head on
the ground he he he acknowledge that
someone higher than him that's not
that's not the same as the Muslims
because you don't prostrate to your
father Jesus did right no you're just
playing semantics I'm not playing
semantics I'm playing identity he
identifi the one who he like for example
if I put my head to the ground and I
prostrate to the God that I believe in
but the God that I believe in is a
statute am I a Muslim
absolutely not right so it's not
semantics it's it's it's worth
identifying who the God is that you're
praying to who you're prostrating to so
it matters if Jesus is prostrating to
his father but you guys don't do that
you guys don't believe that all your
father you don't prostrate to your
father in heaven then you didn't pray
like Jesus
right I disagree what was in Jesus's
heart he was obviously praying to his
his his his maker his creator you say
only one worthy of worship
Allah you say you disagree MH so if I
prostrate to my
statue and I believe that that's my
Creator I believe that that's what I'm
saying is that what what did you know
what was in Jesus's heart and what what
he was yeah I'm I'm using this example
let's say it's in my heart that this
this statute is the creator who created
me and created all things and so I'm
prostrating to it and praying to it and
honoring it like that am I a Muslim
you're a
polytheist nope I'm not a polytheist
because it's the only God I believe in
the only God that I believe in is this
statute I believe this statute is the
one God monotheism is the belief in one
God so I believe in one God my one God
that I believe in is just a statute who
I prostrate to am I the understanding of
one God though and and who who authorize
you to believe in that one God you can't
just make up any one God all like ah
exactly you can't just make up any one
God so it matters who you're saying the
one God is right yes got it and it
matters who you're prostrating to
right yeah so if Jesus is prostrating to
his father and saying that God is his
father is that how Muslims pray do you
pray calling God your father and
prostrating to God who is your father do
you prostrate to your father is that how
you pray we don't we don't use father no
we don't use father then you don't pray
like
Jesus how my son what you
talking
busy sorry about that
son so that yeah yeah carry on carry on
yeah so so you guys don't pray like
Jesus since he prayed prostrating to his
father and saying that God is his
father oh I lost him
I lost
him I'm glad his kid came around and
needs to hear this too both of them need
to hear this we need to set this
straight from the head of the household
to the progyny of the
household all right but I lost him for a
second so let me see if I can bring
someone else up
laxo how you doing oh Nas is back
sorry Nas you back yeah yeah can you
hear me okay yeah yeah I can hear you
did you uh probably accidentally click
out the app or something yeah yeah my
son's messing
about I can't see you I can only see a
white screen I can't or a black screen I
can't see
you yeah can you hear me okay I can hear
you but I can't see
you yeah yeah it's just my my son is is
about you see so okay so you're you're
going to go off camera that's okay mhm
all right but yeah so you guys don't
pray like
Jesus you guys can see him
really I can't see him hold on I'm G
reload my
page or let me just do this hold
on hold on let me be right back can can
you hear me okay yeah hold
on there we go okay got it right
yeah all
right upon like the father thing you
know where he's you know supposedly
calling out to Allah's you know his
father obviously like in in you know in
Judaism and in the past like you know
like God had many sons you know
spiritually in the spiritual sense in
the figurative sense so yeah that's
biblically not islamically islamically
Allah doesn't have any sons in any
sense yeah yeah and know and this this
is why though this is why in the latest
Revelation in the latest Shar of the
Muslims hence like the use of father is
like because it was twisted because it
was wared you know it's been like a no
no now because you know the Quran the
Quran never says that it was ever okay
to do that matter of fact
this it's not silent on the issue
chapter 9 verse3 it says the Jews used
to say Ezra was the son of Allah the
Christians used to say the Messiah is
the son of Allah that is their saying
from their own mouths they imitate the
people who disbelieve of old how deluded
they are Allah's curses on them so
that's that's a group of Jews and a
group of Christians it's not Islam
obviously he didn't do but it's talking
about how PE how when people are saying
that they're sons of God or that certain
people are children of God says that
people used to say this even back then
and they were even disbelievers back
then for saying these things yeah yeah
the them group of Jews and them group of
Christians of course not them but not
Jesus and his followers not the
disciples because even even in
61 you know where where you know it says
you know be all you Believers like be a
party to Allah you know be and then Isam
helpers be helpers of them yeah yeah
exactly and you know who who will help
me you know in in the cause of Allah so
obviously Jesus himself there and then
with these disciples you know they they
were referring to Allah so obviously we
will always look at you know the lens of
the from The quranic View and and that's
and that's backwards it's supposed to be
the other way around you don't look at
the Bible from the Quran view you don't
do that it's you look at the Quran from
the biblical view you don't it's you got
it backwards you don't use the latest
book to then Look Backwards at the
previous and say and judge and determine
what things are supposed to be or say or
mean it's the latter book that's judged
by the older you get what I'm saying so
when you look and you go into the gospel
and you see what Jesus said and you see
what his Apostles
said they taught that God was their was
their father Jesus said that he's the
son of God who came into the world
that's what he said you guys you guys
don't believe that nor do you pray like
that so Jesus does not match the beliefs
of a
Muslim but that's the Jesus being
portrayed in your in your books but you
quoted my
book you quoted it was you that brought
up my book to prove that Jesus was a
Muslim and so I'm just showing you that
from yeah to to illustrate the point
that he he bowed and he went on his face
to pray Allah so do you so do you get
that the reference that you quoted in my
book actually shows the opposite that he
wasn't a
Muslim yeah but your whole argument is
hinging on him referring to Allah's
father absolutely because the Quran is
very clear and very adamant that Allah
is not a
father that's why that matters that
that's like me saying if the verse said
Jesus fell on his face and prostrated
saying my statute let your will be done
not my will if he said my statute and
I'm saying do do Muslims pray to their
statute you be like no but you're you're
you're playing semantics you're you're
focused on the word statute of course I
am because that matters that's a
difference that's a i that that
separates the identity of who God is
according to the statement versus what
you say according to
Islam so it matters Allah says in the
Quran he's not a father you can only be
a slave he has no children he doesn't be
nor is he begotten right it's a lie to
say that to ascribe to him Sons or that
he's a father all of that is a lie Jesus
says he is the father so he's not a
Muslim make
sense and what I'm saying is this is why
the new the new laws they're more
stricter on on the use of father because
you know father was being used Loosely
before and like so you couldn't discern
whether it was being used you know
referring to Allah as like father in the
spiritual sense that you know from him
like you know everything comes the guide
that you know the sustenance and stuff
or like they were you know
ascribing to him like in a in know
degrading
sense hence that's why you know it's
condemned in the Quran is all you know
groups of people who refer to Jesus or
you know as now what what am I what am I
saying that's not connecting with you I
don't I don't understand what not
connecting but do you understand the
point I'm
making I do I do I think like I said you
are hinged
upon you know the wording semantics does
it matter I like like you know there
isn't there like even where all the
prophets known as like does does it
matter who you identify God
as yeah you you identify God as as as he
has revealed himself yeah okay if you
identify God as something other than
what he revealed himself to be are you a
deviant and a
blasphemer either that ignorant yeah
right or ignorant so if you are if I
am um identifying God as a statute am I
a
Muslim no why not maybe that was okay
back in the day why why am why am I not
why am I not a Muslim if I identify the
one God that I believe in as a
statute because that you know that goes
against monism no it doesn't again
monotheism is the belief in one God
that's all it is one true God one true
God who is that is that is the one true
God a statue Allah is the is Allah a
statue that's why the statement it
doesn't just mean you know there's no
God Allah but it means in Ence one only
true only tell me anything is the true
God a
statue of course not okay
so the true God has specific
qualities that make him who he is would
you agree yes so if you believe things
that go outside of those characteristics
and qualities then you believe in a
false god
right say
again if you are believing
in other qualities or
descriptions that do not fit the true
God then you are not believing in the
true God that you're talking about is
that is that correct okay is the true
God you said he's not a statue does he
beget or is he
begotten no does he have any
Partners nope so if I believe in a God
who has partners and I am I believing in
the true
God no if I believe in a God who begets
and I am I believing in the true God
nope okay is the true God a father to
anyone can you can you hear me okay yeah
yeah I can hear you yeah carry on is the
true God our
Father is the true
God a father
no no not in this not in this latest
Revelation no very good so if I'm
believing in this God that I'm saying as
a father then I'm not believing in this
true God that the Quran talks about
right yeah that just means you're out
day you need to get up with the program
okay I need to get up with the program
so Jesus when he says that God is his
father he's not believing in the god
that the Quran describes right
right
yeah the way the Quran describes it now
yeah so then that means that Jesus is
not a Muslim he believed in a different
God than the God that the Quran
describes than this Allah character in
Islam Jesus didn't believe in that so
he's not a Muslim he's not no character
he's the lord of the heavens and the
Earth according to the
Quran but according to Jesus he says the
only true God is the Father John
17:3 so according to Jesus the true God
is his
father in Islam Allah is not his father
so according to Jesus that Allah in the
Quran is not the true God it's a false
god but how do you know he's using
father in like the that's what the
that's what the verses say that you
brought up biological sense yeah he's
saying father but like father is in a
higher authority you know the highest
author it doesn't matter in what any
sense Allah is not a father in any sense
you already said that so it doesn't
matter how he meant
it but that's like I said to you earlier
though that before before because the
term father was used Loosely and it
became you know it was probably allowed
in the previous scriptures and previous
Revelations and where do you get from
where do you get that from that that it
was allowed back then that all so so now
what you're saying is that once upon
time many even like many Jews like they
Once Upon a Time Allah was a father and
then he changed and he's not a father
anymore not father in the you know like
biological sense all right man all right
uh I appreciate you for coming to us I
appreciate you for coming man all right
man take
care this is what this leads to
guys this is what it leads
to in order to try to hold on to Jesus
they got to make stuff up about their
religion go against their Quran go
against the characteristics of this God
that they serve and
worship is what they got to do